high for the day today it was a hot one
but unfortunately
it's going to get even hotter 84 for the
overnight low
115 degrees the record today set back in
1943
thankfully we did not reach that here's
our desert radar now you'll see
storms really favoring utah a doppler
network sweeping around trying to find
those storms
mainly towards phoenix eastern portions
of arizona this time
and we actually had a few thunderstorms
that were firing up in the lincoln
county and southern great basin there
futurecast shows however those chances
of anything happening this week
well not going to happen that high
rotates in from the coast and that's
just going to bring us the heat
that's going to spin all that off
towards the east to press it off towards
the east
away from us and even from arizona too
so all areas will be hot in the desert
southwest here's a look at your
temperature trend now you'll notice
i'll show you the numbers on there take
a look at them all right the record
territories 115 to 116.
we don't think we'll reach those but
you'll notice we'll come a few digits
shy of reaching those
numbers but otherwise way above average
you should be 104 degrees this time of
the year
we're looking at 110 111 friday being
our hottest day
and uh right now it's a heat watch but
could be extended
or upgraded to a heat warning if that
happens
our eight news now storm track rate team
will let you know back live now again
school supply drive these are at 32
locations at smith's
i didn't know about all the children at
shade tree so i'm glad linda explained
that all to us
because now we need to help those kids
out again
there is a lot of obviously clark county
distance learning
but those kids still need those supplies
reporting live at smith's ted florento 8
news now 8 news now
we'll be right back